let's just say you are the pm of canada
let's just play this let's just say game
okay
um
and you watch the decisions justin made
he's your pm you live in that country
how he handled truckers how he handled
vaccine how he handled lockdowns how he
handled everything how would you have
handled some of those things if you were
to pm of canada
well i i'd have to say
that i don't know because
those decisions are extremely
complicated you know and it's it's very
hard to speculate i do have something to
say about that though
that i think is relevant
when i watch
mr trudeau
through
through the lenses that i've developed
over the years
i see someone who never
ever says a true word
and so i've met lots of people like that
they're all persona and everything they
do is crafted in a sense
to
obtain what they think is appropriate in
the situation whatever that might be
it's all instrumentality and so when mr
trudeau comes out
and addresses
his audiences
it's all
it's all a game it's all an act
all of it and so
what i would hope i would have done
differently if i was in that position is
i would have said what i thought
and hope that that
i always think that's the way that
carries the day it doesn't mean you're
right because what the hell do you know
but at least it means you're engaging in
the process that might make you right if
you opened up your eyes in your ears and
listened right and so
what to do isn't
in a complex situation in some sense
isn't as important as how you do it
right what approach do you take when
when
when the chips are down and and things
are tense
the good politicians that i've met
and this is relevant to this
they listen
you know they go out among their people
actually go out and they listen to them
and that way they learn what to do
and that's not opinion polls
opinion polls are and our
my country and yours to a large degree
is ruled by opinion polls to a degree
you can can't possibly imagine because
the politicians won't take
responsibility for saying what they
think and so then they default to their
handlers and their handlers rely on
opinion polls and opinion polls provide
a bad short-term sample of people's
careless thoughts
and you think well you're following the
public it's no you're not
the entire parliamentary system is set
up
to follow the public in an intelligent
way
it's not easy to figure out what people
think
or what they want it isn't even easy for
individuals to figure out what they
themselves think or want it's really
hard and these traditions that we've set
up of representative democracy are ways
of listening to the people that are
measured and thoughtful and long-term
and they're being supplanted by idiot
opinion polls that are run by people who
have instrumental desires they want to
win the next election and i know you
have to win the damn next election you
know but pandering to
a mob
who's frightened because you scared them
that doesn't constitute leadership it's
certainly not democracy there's a reason
we don't have direct democracy
there's a reason for that it's like rule
by impulse it's not a good structure
it's not a good strategy
we figured that out a long time ago our
organizations are way too large and
complex for anything like direct
democracy to work we're going to want to
have a we're going to have a vote on
every issue like obviously not
people just don't have the expertise for
that and it's not like they shouldn't be
consulted they absolutely should be
the voice of the people is the sovereign
master of the political enterprise but
what a leader does is aggregate that
voice
i'll give you an example this is a good
example what a leader does is aggravate
aggregate people aggregate that voice
yes yes yes collects it collects it so i
interviewed jimmy carr the british
comedian he's very very smart car and i
asked him how he did what he did and i
kind of knew this from other comedians
i've talked to he said
the comedy stand-up comedy is the most
dialogical of all the artistic
enterprises i thought what do you mean
by that because he actually you have a
monologue
what do you mean it's dialogical he said
well before i go out on a tour and he's
had a couple of successful world tours
so that's pretty good when you're that
funny
that's amazing
he said he'd go out and do 100 shows
rogan does the same thing all the
comedians do the same thing
uh uh
louis ck does this they all do it they
go to small clubs
and they try out their material so
they're sitting at home trying to be
funny and sometimes they are and
sometimes they're not and then they go
to an audience and they
lay out some jokes and
sometimes people laugh a lot and
sometimes they don't
and so the comedians who do this
repeatedly listen
and then they collect all the things
that people think are funny and so isn't
it so cool is that you don't even have
to be that funny
in some sense to be a comedian
you have to be a little bit funny and
then you really have to listen
and so if you go out to your audience
and you tell them jokes and they tell
you what's funny then you can collect
all the things that everyone thinks is
funny and then you can go on a world
tour and just say things that everyone
thinks are funny exactly it's so cool
it's that that's the pathway hence
aggregate
exactly exactly so so when the comedians
are doing what what a political leader
who who who is functioning properly does
they're doing exactly the same thing
um i i talked in at length to a canadian
politician preston manning he's on the
right of the of the political spectrum
um and he built a political party from
scratch in canada and became the leader
of the opposition which is no trivial
thing to do in the span of a single
lifetime or even in the fraction of a
career which is what he did and he told
me um
that what he really liked was going out
to make a speech but that wasn't the
part he really liked he really liked the
question period
because people would just tell him what
they were concerned about and then he
derived the policies for his party
as a consequence of addressing those
concerns so it was really a bottom-up
enterprise
and so
i would hope that had i been in that
position
i would do what i'm doing
when i'm on my tour which is
watching people and listening to them
and then responding and this happens
first of all when i lecture
which isn't exactly the right word
when i explore ideas in front of people
i'm watching them like a hawk
blinded as i am by the lights you know
but i'm watching to see if people are
following and and modifying what i'm
saying to make sure that everybody's
staying on the track and then
i have thousands of people
i have had thousands of people meet me
in meet and greets after the talks and
then on the street
and i always listen to them
and so
then i can address that those concerns
and then that keeps the
situation dynamic right and
so in in in the uk in the house of
parliament there's this great dome at
the center of the building
and it's the lobby
and that's where the word lobbyist comes
from by the way and the
citizens of the uk have the right to
enter the lobby and petition their
their member of parliament at any time
essentially
and so the lobby is where the voice of
the people meets the voice of their
representatives and it's the center of
the british house of parliament and it's
it's built that way architecturally
which is so brilliant it's
stunningly brilliant the way that that's
laid out and
that's exactly right because the people
are somewhat inarticulate like the
truckers
like they're not making an argument in
some sense they're bringing their trucks
to ottawa right they're showing not tell
us yes exactly and and and and
people who aren't primarily intellectual
let's say
they have to act out their moral
presuppositions
in a more concrete manner but that
doesn't mean they're wrong at all it
doesn't mean that at all
um
and so then
the job of a leader is to
note that inarticulate expression
and to give it voice
publicly
in in speeches let's say but also
to
have that voice manifest itself in the
body of laws that governs all of us
that's how the system works
and so
and the alternative is to
dismiss
that
and that's not a good alternative
or to demonize it so if you enjoy this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]